no puedo respirar la frase se ha
convertido en la expresión más cura de
la opresión y la violencia del racismo
sistémico en eeuu y en el mundo entero
fue pronunciada por georges floyd
mientras el expolicía derecho bin le
ahogaba durante nueve minutos hace ya un
año este domingo miles de personas han
conmemorado el primer aniversario del
asesinato
y el martes hará un año ha sido un año
muy largo un año muy difícil ha sido muy
frustrante para mí mi familia la vida
cambio en un abrir y cerrar de ojos
todavía no sé por qué rating
a finales de abril tras tres semanas de
juicio seguidas alrededor del planeta el
expolicía derecho bing fue declarado
culpable de asesinato en segundo y
tercer grado y de homicidio en segundo
grado
nosotros el jurado declaramos al acusado
culpable de asesinato en segundo grado
una sentencia histórica y simbólica solo
durante el juicio a su fin murieron tres
personas al día en enfrentamientos con
la policía
la mayoría afro estadounidenses y
latinos nombres como down right andrew
brown y brión a taylor entre tantos
otros recuerdan que un año y 140
reformas policiales después queda un
largo camino por recorrer por mar fue un
asesinato a plena luz del día y mostró
al mundo del racismo sistémico del que
habló la vicepresidenta el racismo
sistémico que mancha nuestra nación
el asesinato de floyd desató las
protestas anti racistas más
multitudinarias en décadas y puso las
reformas policiales en el centro de la
agenda política ahora la propuesta de
una ley federal para la protección de
derechos civiles y para la reforma de la
policía lleva su nombre
george's floyd justice en policía
[Música]